[Music]
and where'd you go new
where did you go to the bar Oh God
amen mysteriously disappeared after
working on a secret project words mm-hmm
what is this guy a FBI agent I disappear
after secret projects all the time like
when when I go to the bathroom that's no
secret
we hear it we also smell it and we smell
it all right so the story is about this
man named Bruno Mars Ferno gorgeous Oh
what again vodkas he's 24 years old he's
a psychology student and he from Brazil
the most useless major ever because that
was my major yeah so Bruno has been
obsessed with alien life so he loves
aliens and he has a nice butt and he
knows jujitsu but I generally introduce
everyone from Brazil has like the nicest
butt mm-hmm and they love plantains we
like to make generalizations very wide
ones here hmm wide like the butt from
Brazil Oh Bruno he disappeared
back in March 27 mmm so he went missing
after during the time when his parents
went out for a month-long vacation I was
about 22 days a month long vacation I
know everybody's trying to escape this
loser retired people know but that's
just life you know because if you're
retired your whole life vacation now
she's like they wanted to go away one
month my my parents go on like one-month
cruises that's not a vacation the other
retired yeah that's like normal that's
life that's regular like now well maybe
he's so stupid everyone wants to run
away from him so the parents went on a
one-month trip yes that's where they
were so during that one month he
transformed his entire bedroom into this
like weird shrine sort of thing which
I'm going to show you a video god of his
bedroom
I wanna see he sounds like a flat
earther low key though those videos
almost got me convinced almost yeah
because I personally haven't seen the
north I mean the South Pole so I can't
say [ __ ] what but I did fly over the
North Pole so I can say [ __ ] yeah there
you go
I'm with you then Bruno started this
work that that's displayed in his whole
room he started this back in 2013 and so
he would tell his family that he was
working on a secret project that will
ultimately help humanity but he wouldn't
tell his family like any details he
would just ask for money to find this
secret project oh my god dude I hate
what people do this oh I got this secret
for life but you have to solve the
puzzle then you're worthy if you are a
good person you just [ __ ] make it
easy here it is the secret of life just
sleep more and eat healthy now you know
like something like like what the [ __ ]
dude you like that ah I have to I have
the special key it has to be like a
movie where it's like only you the
chosen one can go out and find this
special [ __ ] key that can unlock
immortality and all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
this [ __ ] mysterious [ __ ] fine let's
just end the article hello Maura people
I just hate people that do this
doo-doo-doo-doo or he's clearly seeking
for attention or he's on to something
I wonder it's kind of like when people
say like the fountain but you still
exist the psyche still exists and
included it actually exists in the first
place what are you telling me out of all
these millions of years nobody knows
what that [ __ ] is Paul it's at BJ's key
every single rupee there is the Fountain
of Youth
hmm so he knows the secret of life well
I don't know the secret what he's been
doing and keep this [ __ ] up so what
about the other one he's been working on
14 handwritten note book there you go
and everything is encode everything in
the entire room which I'm going to show
you videos like not if I saw this you
did it's a whole head of thought I put a
song we did it here but we do that
probably on my own
so I was not really okay so there's a
statute in the Senate yeah that's what I
saw so what that statue is it's a statue
of Italian Renaissance philosopher
Giordano Bruno Oh
keeping the reincarnation of him I have
an answer you got to find Tom Hanks only
he could figure [ __ ] like this out he's
done it three times already at the
Louvre in DaVinci Code yeah somewhere
else and angels and demons yes and a
third rise in Rome yeah wait Tom Hanks
was in DaVinci Code yeah yeah professor
Langdon Langdon yeah my [ __ ] on my
dad I'm [ __ ] this up with the Nicolas
Cage one hmm
oh yeah the one that's missing national
treasure they saw DaVinci call the Vinci
Code is where what's his name like
Tyrone Biggums was like whipping himself
yeah okay well I'm not Tyrone Biggs I'm
Jessica Ashley Larry I'm sorry yeah my
bad dude I thought that what we need is
Forrest Gump which is Tom Hanks but I
like the Forrest Gump version of him
better well what are you telling [ __ ]
then no but he'd accidentally luck
luckily getting [ __ ] so he's gonna fall
upon this accidentally and everyone's
gonna think he's a genius when he's
really [ __ ] done okay he's gonna fall
in love with the [ __ ] that give him
AIDS yeah Jenny Janus
Italian Renaissance philosopher he was
one of the first people on earth to
claim that there was existence outside
in the universe so here the first person
who believed in healing and that was the
first person who ever smoked weed since
he named himself Bruno did he change his
name to Bruno that's not a question or
did it was it a coincidence and then he
was like home my name is Bruno I know
the secret so I'm going to look for the
Philosopher's Bruno and that's the
mention on that shirt I think he watched
a movie Bruno and the part where they
wiggled a dick in a circle like that he
decided that that was his passion for
life and he became Bruno that's perfect
that makes absolute sense I get it I get
it all right so it could be I'm going to
show you guys the video now Oh pursue
spin me right
I don't know oh he looks no that's the
real first brew no no the second the
Renaissance Bruno has his last name this
is his first name he looks like he wants
to be a philosopher it's a quick of
painting from life back in the day why
is he holding a book I feel high right
now because it doesn't look like it's a
modern photo is this a modern Sun it's a
modern photo he looks like Emma just got
here but he took that fiction on purpose
it has that like toys look yeah it looks
a part of a clergy or something yeah all
right so you're a miniature I'm going to
play the video of his bedroom now it's
nuts those that is right yeah thank you
and the Wold is like writing everywhere
everything is writing everything is in
cones and these are all their hand rule
you have to be Gordon is a crazy sticker
project oh I already know I thought um
you imagine that door walk into all the
stones and I like weird like diagrams
and all everything is roaming the world
on
Jennifer unfortunately they're kind of
the causes yeah yeah because there was a
creative waterline yeah you know meaning
a life holy laughs that sucks
it's loving it ahead Sarah number have a
syllabus are this is also painting of
him and knowing is why does the alien
look like all the aliens in the movie so
yeah that's true I wish mammals
different kind of like oh that movie so
the alien right home for rifle yeah you
didn't know if there's aliens out there
and they find contact with us and I see
them land and they come out ain't coming
for you don't lie on the stand if they
come out and they look just like God
Emily pierced um I guess so [ __ ]
anti-climatic no we found you like they
get to last back of the spaceship will
see us okay but what did it talk about
that that means a weird alien I don't
think he made that connection I think
he's just disappointed I said what I've
used to be honest I really excited too I
think so we're an alien to somebody out
there because I can't survive when I'm
just in out in the wild like my dog can
like we're not meant to be in this
planet anything you're saying
like my dog let her loose she could
survive in the force me on the other
hand let him loose let me loose I need
it I don't have the skills I don't know
how to stay warm I don't know nothing
and Alan you don't have to worry about
me
yeah but the desert here it gets cold at
night and then they got tarantulas that
will eat your Apple here well not
tarantulas but maybe some kind of bugs
watch I'll show you guys some more still
from that video but it's like you can
see all these books you skipped two
through four you know what I will say
though you're a very organized human
being and I do appreciate that because
there's so much symmetry in the place
look I'm writing it's amazing all the
symbols you created
look at that looks like you did it by
half it's pretty crazy Wow he's an
artist I bet you there's a reason for
that guy looking at something so they're
saying he's reincarnated from the
original burger she might be you look
you look just I can the hairline could
look cool in like the forehead
yeah the eyebrows if they zoom out it's
him standing on a soccer ball wait so he
just disappeared
yeah so he just vanished they're saying
like he took a backpack with him but
they haven't heard anything from him
since he disappeared
dude this will better come Batman cuz I
got a piece of evidence I don't like how
there's a big code and then everyone's
now going to have all these theories and
try to solve it like he could just been
like I got the cheat sheet this parents
worth you're worried if you really
wanted to help the world so odd because
his parents aren't all that worried for
him they think that his brain is on
purpose to like push his his whole
agenda of like publishing me 14 hooks
the his sister saying like digital
stupid he's been doing this since 5
years old it first started off with a
pop-up book that he made a [ __ ]
kindergarten and then he was hiding in
the closet all day long and everyone
thought that he ran away but he's been
doing this in [ __ ] junior high he
made a movie and then he was just
sleeping in the tree house that dumb ass
I don't know if you disappeared before
but yeah like his sister saying like
obviously they are worried for his
safety because they don't know where he
is or who he's with or they haven't
gotten in contact with him at all so
he's disappeared but they're saying like
we're hoping that this is all just part
of this plan and I he'll come home soon
one day well he can't come home he went
with the aliens yeah it's only her thing
like did he get abducted by the Eels or
he traveled through time that's the only
two reasons why he's not there or he
just went to another I don't think he's
at Eddie's house Eddie his best friend
his best time Eduardo in Brazil but
Eddie for Americans he's got a friend's
house okay excited
thanks for watching just kidding news
guys don't forget to comment down below
we want to hear what you say only if
it's positive remember that to watch
more videos go up here baby
[Music]